البلدين بما فيها الملف النووي
الايراني. الامير السعودي بدأ
بذلك حربا عالمية. نعم يا سادة
فحرب التنين الصيني امام المارد
جولته الاوروبية بزيارة اليونان
لتوقيع اتفاقيات عسكرية
رويترز عن مصادر مطلعة ترقب
لاعلان حزب ثالث بامريكا تحت اسم
القيادة الاستراتيجية الامريكية
ان الولايات المتحدة بحاجة
الغربية بسبب حرب اوكرانيا عادت
موسكو لتلمح باحقيتها في الجزيرة
والذهب فيها اصبحت هي الولاية
التاسعة والاربعين في امريكا.
قرابة قرن من سيطرتهم عليها كان
الشعب الامريكي رافضا في البداية
المهمة الى ناسا او تغييرها
باخرى جديدة. قلق امريكي. باعها
سيتم انشاء محطة خاصة بروسيا وفق
ما اكده يوري بوريوسوف رئيس
هذه الاسلحة ستصعد الصراع مع
موسكو. مشيرة ان هذه الخطوة
لدعم الجيش الاوكراني بالتصدي
للتحركات العسكرية الروسية شرقية
الثالثة كما تفعلها بين حين
واخر. فلماذا كل هذا يا احفاد
عرضة للتغير المناخي في العالم.
تتفاقم ازمة المياه في العراق
العطشة مع ارتفاع درجة الحرارة
بشكل كبير ونقصان مخزون المياه
في العراق بنسبة ستين بالمائة
ليكون بين الدول الخمس الاكثر
اصفرت حقول المزارعين الذين
يبحثون عن المياه لري اراضيهم
جريح. مظاهرات حاشدة على طريقة
سيريلانكا والحكومة تدعو للحوار
في العراق وكان ذلك لا يكفي.
فبعد عامين من القحط والجفاف
الروس في حربهم على كييف لم
يسخروا كافة امكاناتهم العسكرية.
وواشنطن توحي بحرب قادمة.
والعالم يقول كفانا حروب لقد
الذي قاله لبعضهما تفصيلا يا
ترى. الجنون لم يبدأ بعد. زعيم
اجراء التجارب الصاروخية لكن
ماذا عن نووي المجنون سلاح كيم
يحذر الصين من غزو تايوان وبكين
ترد ان تايوان شأن داخلي ولا شأن
لاحد بها. فيما تايوان تجري
تدريبات عسكرية بالذخيرة الحية
المتحدة ان تفهم ذلك. وهي النار
نفسها التي تبادل الرئيسان جو
لنتحارب فانا مستعد لكل ما
تطلبون. كم يدعو واشنطن الى حرب
محمد بن سلمان يصل الى فرنسا
محادثات ثنائية مع ماكرون في قصر
باختلاط نظام سياسي قائم اساسا
على حزبين. ولي العهد السعودي
تسلل القلق الى قلوب الامريكان.
الاحداث والتطورات. قال رئيس
باسلحة كهذه. فكيف سيرد? موسكو
واشنطن وحيدة. روسيا تعلن
التأهب لخطر قادم من سد النهضة
بسبب تخوفات من ملء ثالث لماذا
اوكرانيا. تاريخ جد لمنطقة
الاسكا في اقليم المحيط الهادئ
صحيفة جورنال الامريكية التي
اكدت ان كانت لديها مخاوف من ان
لضم هذه الولاية المتجمدة لكنه
وبعد اكتشاف ثروات ضخمة من النفط
الروس لامريكا بسبعة ملايين
دولار. وعاد الخلاف عليه بعد حرب
تصر نانسي بيلوسي على زيارة
تايوان? رغم انها يمكن ان تشعل
لمواصلة تحديث نظام والتحكم
النووي الخاص بها للتصدي لاي
تنصت او تسلل الكتروني ومن ثم
تتجاوز اي تهديدات محتملة.
قدرات الجيش للقيام بعمليات
هجومية ضد دول الناتو ان لزم
الاليزيه خلال جولته الاوروبية.
المحادثات ركزت على العلاقات بين
كان قد حذر الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
ان روسيا لن تتوقف في اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا اضافة الى استخدام اقل
لانظمة عسكرية دقيقة وقبل الناتو
الى الامام بهدف استقطاب ملايين
الامريكيين الذين ضاقوا ذرعا
اكبر الولايات الامريكية مساحة
وافق الروس على بيع الاسكا بعد
التدريبات المشتركة الامريكية
الكورية الجنوبية وتبدلت الكورية
واقتصادية لكن لماذا زار بن
سلمان فرنسا? السودان يرفع حالة
الان معرفة كيفية ادارة المحطة
مساعدة الروس انه امر في غاية
اما اليوم وبعد مرور مئة وخمسين
على بيعها. وبعد العقوبات
وتمنعها من السقوط في المدار
واوضح الموقع انه يجب تسليم
انسحابها من محطة الفضاء الدولية
بحلول عام الفين واربعة وعشرين.
لكن ما وراء السطور اكبر بكثير.
تغيير الوضع الراهن برمته. ربما
الصعوبة بحسب الموقع فروسيا تدير
انظمة التحكم الخاصة بدفع المحطة
وانها ستستعيدها اذا لم يكف
الامريكان عن عقوباتهم وهناك
مؤسسة الفضاء قرار الانسحاب اثار
مخاوف من تأثيره السلبي على
لم يظهر بعد. هدف بوتين القادم.
موسكو بدأت عملياتها العسكرية في
الاوكرانية. بوتين كان قد حذر
برد حازم وقوي على من يمد كييف
المحطة الدولية. موقع فوكس
الامريكي افاد بان على امريكا
عثمان؟ واين حق الجار على جاره؟
دعم امريكي. نفاثة من الحقبة
المائية وكأن ذلك كله لا يكفي
فتعود تركيا لتقصف العراق للمرة
اوكرانيا باسلحة متقدمة تشمل
طائرات نفاذة فائقة الدقة وفق
بشكل متواصل. وذلك بسبب انشاء
ايران وتركيا مشاريع الطاقة
السوفيتية في طريقها لاوكرانيا.
خطوة استراتيجية كانت مؤجلة تهدف
وجنوبي البلاد. الادارة
الامريكية تعتزم اليوم تزويد
الكهربائية على نهري دجلة
والفرات وبناء السدود والحواجز
او المادية. وهو ما يفسر
استخدامه لقوة جو محدودة في
استعداد بلاده لاي صدام عسكري مع
امريكا. المجنون انذر رئيس كوريا
ودول الناتو واوروبا هي الهدف
فما هو الهدف يا بوتين. عراق
كما ان الرئيس بوتين لم يأمر
بالتعبئة العامة للحفاظ على
الهجوم على احدى الدول هكذا يرى
الحلف هدف موسكو القادم على ان
الجنوبية وجيشها بالابادة في حال
اقدموا على اي محاولات خطيرة.
ستزيد فعالية الجيش الاوكراني
حيث ان هذه المقاتلات ستمكن كييف
الامر. وعلى الرغم من الخسائر
التي تكبدها جيشه سواء البشرية
من ضرب خلف الخطوط الروسية
وتوفير غطاء جوي للقوات
اوكرانيا بهدف واضح منع تمدد حلف
الناتو وحماية حدودها الغربية.
التوتر بين الكوريتين منذ عامين
لكنه ازداد ولاول مرة بينهما بعد
كوريا الشمالي يأمر بالتأهب
وتجهيز قوات الردع النووية ويؤكد
بايدن وشيجي بينج كرتها بالصوت
والصورة باتصال هاتفي. فبايدن
بالمقابل حملت الصين امريكا
عواقب تلك الزيارة فما الذي ينوي
منطقة عازلة حول طائرة بيلوسي
ومروحيات في حالة استعداد في
سئمنا لكن ما دار في الاتصال بين
الرئيسين لم يفصح عنه بعد. فما
فما هدف هذه الزيارة? سجال
الاقوياء. اقوى دولتين في
ما سيعرض سلامة بيلوسي للخطر.
لذلك يكثف الجيش الامريكي
وسفن حربية وانظمة مراقبة للرحلة
جن جنون الامريكان مع انشاء
السفن. ما كل هذا الرعب من بكين
انتشار لفرق الانقاذ في المنطقة.
بيلوسي تنوي زيارة تايوان رغم
معارضة الصين لهذه وواشنطن تأخذ
الاكثر سخونة في العالم. امريكا
تخشى وقوع خطأ صغير او سوء فهم
العراق يتعرض للقصف جديد وهذه هي
النتائج. امير السعودية في فرنسا
احتياطها تحسبا لاي هجوم.
والبنتاجون يضع خططا لحماية
الصيني يرد ويقول ان من يلعب
بالنار ستحرقه. وعلى الولايات
بيلوسي خلال زيارتها المحتملة
لتايوان على اعتبار انها المنطقة
تحركاته في المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ بمرافقة طائرات مقاتلة
العالم? الصين وامريكا قاب قوسين
او ادنى من مواجهة عسكرية. بكين
وحيدة في الفضاء والامريكان
يعضون اصابع الندم. وزير صيني
وسط تهديدات الصين والتوترات
والتحركات الاخيرة بين بكين
اصحاب العيون الضيقة فعلا? هل هي
مقدمة لحرب عالمية. الرئيس
قد تهاجم طائرة رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي نانسي بيلوسي بحسب
عسكرية مفتوحة. هكذا يرى الغرب
الهدف الروسي القادم بعد وامريكا
يتعرض لموقف محرج ولافروف يعطيه
الامان ليضج العالم كله بالضحك.
روسيا تهدد امريكا باستعادة جزء
من الاراضي الامريكية فكيف ذلك?
تشعل فتيل الحرب مع روسيا بهذه
الخطوة بينما تترك موسكو واشنطن
الصيني. فما الذي جرى يا ترى
انتم تبحثون عن الحرب؟ اذا هيا
امريكا والصين. ياتي الرد من
بايدن باتصال هاتفي للرئيس
ذلك. هكذا قالت الصين فهل تشعل
نانسي بيلوسي حرب الباسوس بين
الامريكي قد تعني هلاك العالم
اجمع.
لا تلعبوا معنا فنحن لا نمزح.
وعلى الولايات المتحدة ان تفهم